[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 segundo bloque económico de nuestra
linda mañana de miércoles Daniel y vamos
a comenzar con un nuevo dato de
inflación decepcionante para Reino Unido
ahí no está tan linda la mañana
para los británicos porque conocieron
que su inflación se ubicó en 11,1%
interanual en octubre es la más alta en
41 años y también representa un gran
salto desde el 10,1% de septiembre está
impulsada por supuesto por alimentos y
energía estos datos se conocen un día
antes de que el ministro de finanzas
Jeremy Hunt presente un muy esperado
paquete económico al respecto de esto
Dijo el Primer Ministro Richie sunat
durante su intervención de hoy en la
Cumbre del g20 en Bali
mi prioridad número uno es asegurarme de
que podamos lidiar con la situación
económica que enfrentamos en casa hoy
tenemos más noticias sobre la inflación
es lo primero que está en la mente de la
gente es lo que está causando más a
abrir facturas ver que llegan correos
electrónicos con precios en aumento y es
por eso que es correcto que lo
enfrentemos y mañana el ministro de
finanzas establecerá un plan que nos
permitirá hacer eso
necesitamos tomar medidas decisivas en
casa para que nuestros préstamos y
deudas sigan una trayectoria sostenible
lo haremos porque eso nos ayudará a
abordar la inflación cambiamos de tema
porque la agencia internacional de
energía vamos un panorama pesimista para
el mercado petrolero Dani lo hizo Raúl
en su informe mensual cuya principal
conclusión en el más reciente es que el
mercado mundial tendrá todavía más
presión debido al castigo que occidente
planea imponerle a Rusia otro de los
castigos le va a dejar de comprar crudo
a partir de diciembre y sus derivados
desde comienzos del próximo año las
importaciones de la Unión Europea
cayeron desde 2,5 millones de barriles
diarios En que estaban antes de la
guerra es decir enero de este año apenas
1,4 millones de bar diarios hoy pues
China India y Turquía han venido
compensando con creces esa caída le
están comprando 1,2 millones de barriles
diarios más a Rusia hasta y Rusia está
bien el problema vendrá a partir del 5
de diciembre cuando Rusia tenga que
redirigir más de un millón de barriles
que la Unión Europea le va a dejar de
comprar y a su vez Bruselas debe
conseguir un nuevo proveedor Estados
Unidos y Noruega se han ofrecido le
están ayudando bastante la Unión Europea
y han venido subiendo sus ventas pero no
hay certeza de que sí será suficiente
veremos qué pasa a partir de enero del
próximo año Así es mi Dani Y en Estados
Unidos las tasas altas ya empiezan a
incentivar la compra de la vivienda
Bueno como ya lo hemos dicho acá muchas
veces y lo Seguiremos diciendo la
principal arma que usan las autoridades
para afrontar una inflación desenfrenada
son las tasas de interés y así frenan el
consumo en Estados Unidos este antídoto
está mermando la capacidad de los
ciudadanos para adquirir casas y
terrenos rami nos cuenta detalles
el llamado sueño americano ha quedado
condicionado por la situación económica
en Estados Unidos la creciente inflación
y el encarecimiento del costo de vida
provocaron que el acceso a un inmueble
sea difícil para los ciudadanos y
generaron una caída en las ventas Bueno
creo que en este punto Estamos buscando
esa corrección en el mercado y está
sucediendo con las tasas de interés
actualmente en 7%. realmente Es un shock
para algunos compradores
sin embargo otros vendedores se
mantienen optimistas Y esperan que la
situación se normalice pronto
sinceramente no estoy de acuerdo ni
justifico este gran miedo no creo que
sea lo que la gente está construyendo
con las opiniones divididas analistas
aseguran que las tasas de interés
bajarán cuando se reduzca la inflación y
mientras tanto ofrecen otras
alternativas
creo que hay un par de soluciones una es
ahorrar un poco más y la otra es comprar
una casa más barata de lo que sería de
otro modo
la combinación de altas tasas de interés
Y todavía mucha incertidumbre sobre la
inflación significa que la gente está
postergando las compras creo que va a
continuar por un tiempo con más del 7%
el mercado inmobiliario estadounidense
afronta la mayor tasa hipotecaria desde
el 2002 y duplica el pico máximo
registrado en 2021 en tanto que según la
asociación de banqueros hipotecarios la
demanda de hipotecas está en su ritmo
más lento desde 1997
Y repasemos cómo están los mercados
está preparando para la apertura en
medio de datos que se conocen hoy sobre
ventas minoristas y después de cerrar al
alza el martes a pesar de las tensiones
geopolíticas en Europa las bolsas operan
en rojo a medida que están afectandose
por el nerviosismo mundial tras el
lanzamiento de un misil supuestamente
ruso en territorio polaco hacía por su
parte cerró mixto con variaciones muy
leves porque el mercado está esperando
un mayor desarrollo frente a todo esto
sucedido en Polonia para saber Hacia
dónde dirigir su dinero hablando de
igual si me acordé de tanto usted
ahorita que estuve por allá ah bueno Qué
rico Me encantaría estar desde Wall
Street en reportaje reportando bueno
Daniela lo vamos a hacer algún día
la esperanza lo último que se pierde
como siempre Gracias Dani por toda la
información económi